beaucoup de films qui ressemblent à des
films d'action, le personnage principal, c'est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment dur, vous savez
et où vous ne voyez pas vraiment beaucoup d'
émotion en eux, vous savez, il y a très
occupé à survivre dans le
genre de femmes vraiment dures et chaque  c'est en fait une
épave émotionnelle et quand le film
commence, elle est une épave émotionnelle absolue
et pourtant elle parvient toujours à
survivre de cet endroit encore et encore
et encore, donc c'était très très
intrigant pour moi et j'ai aussi vraiment aimé
l'idée de faire un plus  sorte
de film d'action intimiste où tout se passe
au même endroit tout se passe dans un seul
appartement et on ne s'ennuie pas un
instant
le défi de continuer à transformer
le lieu et le personnage et continuer
à surprendre le public minute par
minute c'était passionnant  pour moi et et
et le fait que le script l'ait fait avec tant de
succès et juste au moment où vous pensez
à ce qui pourrait arriver d'autre maintenant, vous
seriez à nouveau tellement surpris, alors j'adore
ça à propos de la fi  lm et je pense que le
public va vraiment aimer l'
expérience de voir un film d'action que
vous n'admirez pas de loin mais
qui vous capture émotionnellement
dès le début et vous maintient
émotionnellement impliqué dans un frisson
jusqu'au  se terminer d'une manière très personnelle d'une
manière très intime,
j'ai pensé que l'idée de jouer un
personnage qui
découvre qu'il y a tellement plus de
force en elle qu'elle ne l'aurait jamais soupçonné
et le fait que le film ait réussi à faire
vivre au public sa
découverte avec Everly ensemble c'est
quelque chose que cela va faire
que notre public va se connecter
au personnage et tout le monde
s'identifiera un peu et s'enracinera
car c'est un film que j'aimerais voir
et je pense que chaque femme va aimer
ce film parce que son
sa douleur est si réelle et c'est vraiment
intense mais c'est tellement plein d'explosion
et d'intensité aussi d'une manière très masculine
et de tension et vous ne savez pas
ce qui se passe et je veux dire  c'est tellement
intense psychologiquement que parfois une
partie du soulagement vient du
moment d'action et de tout le tournage et vous faites
presque une pause de comme ce qui
va se passer ce qui va se passer
ce qui va se passer donc je pense que
c'est c'est définitivement un  vertu
du film pour pouvoir attirer le
public féminin et masculin
la meilleure chose que je puisse retirer de ce
film qui me rend très fier est
que j'ai vraiment l'impression que chaque jour nous nous sommes
présentés et nous avons élevé le film
tout le monde impliqué élevé  le film à un
meilleur niveau chaque jour quand nous montrions
tout ce qu'il y avait sur la page tout
ce que vous pouviez imaginer à
la minute où nous nous sommes tous réunis et
nous y sommes engagés tous les
soirs, je pense que tout le monde peut convenir que vous
rentreriez chez vous en pensant que quoi  a été fait ce
jour-là était tellement mieux que vous pourriez
peut-être imaginer oh que cela ou tout
ce que c'était sur la page
Joe est comme un très jeune d'esprit et
il a tellement d'énergie et nous v  J'ai eu tellement de
chance qu'il le fasse parce que ce film a
été si exigeant, il est toujours
là, plein d'énergie et tellement prêt à partir et
cela a été vraiment utile, vous savez, d'
avoir un moteur et je suis vraiment aussi très
reconnaissant à Joe parce qu'il est  été un
aventurier absolu en se présentant et en
découvrant ce que nous pouvons faire de mieux
aujourd'hui
dans mes propres catégories personnelles quand je
pense à Everly
je n'y pense pas je ne pense pas
qu'Everly ce sera un film d'action
parce que je  Je veux devenir une star de cinéma d'action
Je pense qu'Everly et j'espère
que c'est un très bon film qui n'était
qu'un bon film et certaines personnes
penseront que c'est un thriller ou un drame ou un
film d'action et ça n'a pas d'importance mais
c'est  ne sera jamais juste un
film d'action ce n'est pas un film que je pense quand les
gens y pensent ils sont juste c'est une
autre série d'action jamais ça je pense que
c'est vraiment unique en son genre